[Music]
snowshoes are designed to help you
maintain the weight of your body on top
of the snow as opposed to sinking in
and with every pair of snowshoes
there's a story
i'm bill murkowski i'm a snowshoe maker
and a snowshoe collector
over the years i've collected over 200
pairs as far as we know that's the
largest collection of snowshoes in the
world
for the native americans snowshoes were
not a convenience they're critical
[Music]
an individual may have three or four or
five different pairs of shoes that he
used for different conditions there was
a shoe for spring for deep fluffy snow
for straight travel there is a wide
range of designs
i first got started using snowshoes as a
young fella i spent a good part of my
life in the woods trapping fishing and
hunting
in the mid 80s i was flying in northern
quebec and came upon a free winter camp
and found a pair of traditional native
snowshoes being a snowshoe maker i had
an appreciation for the for the
unbelievable craftsmanship and skill
that went into making these traditional
snowshoes from that point i kind of
embarked on a quest to find some of
these other villages that had snowshoe
makers
i visited every native community in
quebec in the yukon several in the
northwest territories in ontario alaska
all up and down the north shore of the
st lawrence
what i tried to do is to ask them about
their techniques things like how do you
know what kind of wood you want to use
how do you know which tree is right then
why is you have this kind of a weave in
it
in the process of all this documenting
and visiting i learned a considerable
amount about crafting shoes myself
it's given me just a phenomenal
appreciation
for
not only their skill but their lifestyle
[Music]
the primary focus at this point should
be to get this collection
in a situation where it's available for
people to study for scholars
and for people to see
i know other people have collected
snowshoes but i don't think anyone has
ever done it
on this scale
i don't think it's anything that could
ever be done again simply because that
skill is is that lost
it's really the last of the traditional
snowshoemakers